so I want to go through sort of three
different reactions to this mass
shooting that we had in Las Vegas about
a day and a half ago one is from a
lunatic Christian pastor the other is
from a country music artist and then
third we're gonna look at the National
Rifle Association okay so the NRA
apparently realizes that they're pro-gun
apologia might come off as I guess
offensive or maybe insensitive is the
word because they have made an
interesting decision with regard to
their political ads just a day and a
half after the biggest mass shooting in
American history the NRA has endorsed
because they endorse candidates
I almost said they endorse Republicans
it's basically Republicans that they
endorse the NRA has endorsed Republican
Ed Gillespie for governor in Virginia
and they've also in Virginia endorsed
Republican John D Adams so the NRA has
this fund called the political victory
fund which specifically run ads runs ads
to help candidates and they were
planning on running ads in favor of both
Gillespie and Adams in Virginia and
according to medium buying medium buying
is a company that they track ads
spending after the Las Vegas shooting
took place the buying agency decided to
postpone the NRA political ads for eight
days okay medium buying on Twitter said
that the NRA PVF TV ad spending that was
scheduled to start tomorrow has been
postponed and the new start date is
going to be October 10th
so these ads were specifically pro-gun
about those two candidates Gillespie and
Adams the ad was going to Hale Gillespie
as a quote leader in the growing
national movement to expand our Second
Amendment freedoms if your message is
only palatable or acceptable when there
hasn't just been a mass shooting then
it's not a good message right the
message from the gun safety advocates
doesn't feel offensive or insensitive
after a mass shooting we need a hundred
percent background checks we need
limitations on what you can buy
we want gun insurance to be required for
every gun owner or licensing whatever
the case may be right the message from
the gun safety advocate doesn't become
offensive when there's just been a mass
shooting that tells us something about
these messages that we hear from the NRA
and this is actually common for the NRA
after there's a shooting they will often
go silent kind of waiting out the grief
if you've never seen an NRA ad before
they are insane I mean they they make it
appear as though we are living in some
kind of dystopian apocalypse here's a
little bit of one just to give you a
sense they use their media to
assassinate real news they use their
schools to teach children that their
president is another Hitler they use
their movie stars and singers and comedy
shows and award shows to repeat their
narrative over and over again and then
they use their ex-president to endorse
the resistance all to make them March
make them protest make them scream
racism and sexism and xenophobia and
homophobia to smash windows burn cars
shut down interstates and airports bully
and terrorize the law-abiding until the
only option left is for the police to do
their jobs and stop the madness and when
that happens they'll use it as an excuse
for their outrage the only way we stop
this the only way we save our country
and our freedom is to fight this
violence of Lies with a clenched fist of
truth yeah doesn't exactly seem
sensitive and empathetic after a mass
shooting some of these ads are actually
close to inciting violence right we're
gonna fight it with a clenched fist
around a gun and it's always the same
routine right after the shooting the
right says it's too soon to talk about
gun safety laws and it's politicizing a
tragedy and then ten days later shooting
what shooting they just go right back to
the normal ads and in this case they're
not even gonna wait the ten days they're
gonna do it after eight days the
reaction of cutting the ads it's almost
as if they recognize that they're
running ads that actively encourage
people to shoot others and now they're
waiting because someone actually shot
others with not one but many of those
guns and I
mentioned this before gun sales are down
under Trump because the NRA is no longer
fear-mongering about the President of
the United States coming for your guns
like they did under Obama a number and
we reported on this a month or two ago a
number of gun manufacturers have said
we've had to revise our estimates of gun
sales downwards because we are just not
seeing the interest in buying guns since
President Trump has become president
because you are not getting the NRA
saying the evil Democratic president is
coming for your gun so you'd better buy
more it's a really sick reality that we
are dealing with here in the United
States that's the reaction from the NRA
the video you just finished watching was
made possible by you through the
membership program you can sign up for
membership at david pakman.com slash
membership we are viewer supported
independent media you can use the coupon
code
I voted 17 for a 40% discount off of
your membership